this is Dunkirk done
Kirk radar actually pg-13 we're not a 13
men were excessive visuals and accents
um you know in this annalee think you've
acted before before Easter because this
okay okay somebody somebody made this
for me this is a terrific Koken Hagen
maybe one for all of us yeah made one
problems but this is the one that she
gave me and I just thought I'd say like
I got this like a couple weeks ago I
thought I'd save it for this because
it's just Dunkirk is on this my
colleague the Thames the Suicide Squad
premiere was it the review I think is
that where she gave it to us right now
no no no this smooth sent in the mail I
didn't go all this I know as I did oh
yeah yes this came in the mail uh so I
just wanted to say and I guess this
lovely letter and it was really sweet
and um yeah just you know it's nice just
to have fans like do something nice and
just we really appreciate it so -
Samantha chase thank you um apparently
you're my biggest fan girl please don't
stalk me but I tell ya I know any free
goods is I think it's awesome and I'm
going to leave it here in the in the
office and yeah so it'll be in the
background from now on so I I hope you
see this because you claim you watch
everything I do hopefully not be
binoculars no but no this is this is
super awesome and I love it and I just
want to put a shout out to just all our
fans we just love this sort of stuff and
we do keep on it - yeah and we kid that
honestly we do yeah it gets to a point
where sometimes like I know what I'm
going to do with like all this stuff but
like it would be appreciate it should be
what for all of us I remember they're
all I think I shared on my facebook so
that's that's pretty cool yeah that's a
while ago but yeah
I don't know I'm can can I stand Oh
garlic girls taking a nap
countdown she's taken he's taking the
nappies to lose like I'm going to pass
because it's very the best full of dumb
crack yeah so anyway oh my god ah yes ah
Dunkirk man here's something I can't
tell how well I'm recommending a good
Crispin Olin project I'll start off but
like where we I think you and I are a
little different I think you're a little
harsher unknown you see I mean I'm even
blanking on the name of it's a space one
Islam I got 40 minutes into haha turned
it off
you couldn't even finish it gonna finish
it so oh yeah nice the one I really
liked I didn't like Interscope um but I
don't know I I think I'm somewhere in
between like I just putting things he's
done that I like
I enjoyed women oh me too no no I like
our next one might be on a movie I want
the prestige David Bowie as some
Nikolai Tesla how can you go wrong with
that um good Dark Knight I like that
again
Dark Knight Rises to be as just a C
movie in the same and so it's mad but I
mean I've seen anymore I really don't
like talking about like moving seems
like produce like Man of Steel and help
right and stuff like that like there's
definitely sort of that damn pond old a
bells going around that was kind of like
I don't know like my son's name is hatch
there's there this idea of what you're
going to get and it was kind of
decreasing the more like these movies
would come out and now we have this one
that I mean seems almost for me kind of
like tailor-made for me kind of not too
light because it's like it's a war
filled by Christopher Nolan who has been
very dialogue heavy about what does it
mean to be a man what does it mean and
I'm thinking like man's it's evolved on
a monster die he's just a head owner of
all the avenues to like just welcome
that that's like so overplayed and this
does such the polar opposite is so often
overcorrect
there is no no it
absolutely Nover correct yeah it is it
might be a great movie but it is an over
correct one in time from like a future
like you want work like I I could have
used a little more dialogue honestly um
not much though no no and it's one this
one we've seen very much sure behind me
yeah yeah should we go through what we
like first and then like yeah okay
that's fair I mean things okay things
that I love is I'm in the big picture
like the big scale um
visually it's amazing um I get I get a
sense of scale the dogfight teams in
particular it's a game changer
like I think from now on we're going to
talk about dog fights like World War two
dog fights if we ever see them again be
like well it's not as good as Dunkirk or
wow that was nearly as good as Dunkirk
or what what star wars did for space
battles this is going to do for that and
very important this is very very
important to get out there we thought on
IMAX
I don't think young fathers way in a
really light and I say that I seems like
Dean gravity it's a totally different my
favorites with all due respect in the
movies there is probably knowing how I'm
going to own it there's no point
um this is a movie made for the big
screen and gravity would seem like loved
that movie is some things of the
characterization I didn't like in that
character but is but when kids and
visuals loved it
don't hold it because I'm just like I
there's nothing I'm really going to get
on the small screen that's going to
compare yet experience I they are bully
action it is the same they're both
experienced movie assistant so much even
though there's a narrative may be very
much about the XP this is if you have a
rich friend maybe you've got one those
giant home theater setups
maybe then it was like yeah it's worth
owning because you could theoretically
maybe compete a bit with but just hit
really close to what happen when an IMAX
like it's very rare there's a movie like
this right I know of nothing like it
reminded me of what I saw Titanic we
you know an hour and a half of a sappy
love story but once that ship starts
sinking I was blown away it's the same
thing here at same thing would seeing
something like Star Wars on the big
screen or Mad Max fury road another one
yeah that I have yet to really watch
religiously on the small screen because
it was just so impressive on the big
screen
that's so a good movie no it's enough I
thought I put it on once and I'm like
it's still a good movie but I'm like not
quite the same like it was so good on
the big scene so huge and something I
thing with the IMAX two is that because
some you might be thinking was it going
to be like dark night or Dark Knight
Rises where it's like the aspect ratio
is so jarring me different that when the
IMAX shot through I never notice no no I
mean they they change the aspect ratio
so that you know with Dark Knight those
black bars are very proud when some
Maxine Zone filmed an IMAX I think some
things weren't ya know and that's the
case you know that's always filmed a
nightmare no no no no no I chef I head
do I got I invited notice I didn't
notice so that tells you how odd ya know
they change the aspect ratio so that
when it does change it it's much more
minimal they didn't do like the super
super white screaming did it where it's
like you know it's kind of like this
white screen where a Dark Knight Rises
you know dark navy of the watching you
have the black bars you know on the
table in detail like that so they should
have this aspect so they went does go
imax it's not as big a difference to a
point where it's hard to notice you have
to actually kind of look to notice that
it's not I don't know which tells me
that visually speaking he be doing
something right you feel like you're
there in like every single shot there's
occasionally like a particular movie
where you know to feel like you're they
know what's with the dogfights bullets
out of nowhere we're coming it's like
you know be like Tom Hardy's I mean and
where's your other one and then always
there's a and like I would jump like
because you would just feel that any man
it duck a little via the the just the
intro with those first few guys getting
picked off and wandering or at like it
remind me of the in terms of the Dark
Knight I thought that was there was
something about those early shots where
with looking up to the skyscrapers and
the people holding the the Joker mask I
got this sense of scale and
Center with the leaflets falling from
the sky with the Germans be happy
sobbing ha ha like I just got this sense
of immediate scale and he's really good
at it
he was good at the dark man here um I
tried to think what else i I thought the
score was good uh my husband to me is
like the new John Williams Danny Elfman
like he just I feel like he never misses
he always even though they can be a
little repetitive I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna go that hard but I think you don't
think of a bad Hans Zimmer score in the
in the film definitely in the film I
thought it worked because it always wins
the heart it was just yeah it always
keeps the heartbeat going it was always
tense which is what you need in this
movie mm-hmm you know I bought film
scores before like Star Wars and Batman
and so I wouldn't buy this like though
there's a lot of picking like chicken
Tom felt like but I feel it in the movie
it really really works because I just
was on the edge of my seat from
beginning to end
yeah what you wonder the most the most
jarring scene I mean without being
giving anything away but I mean like you
know see where character goes into I
think it's in like a train or something
like that goes at this down the Train is
just complete silence yeah and it's like
well it's one of the few times where you
get complete silence a movie and all of
a sudden I hear the ticking and the
music stops and he just falls asleep but
it's silent you're just like wow - I
also don't come from almost
yeah the cinematography is great there's
one shot in particular I love where
there's a ship sinking and so it's
capsizing the water comes yeah and he
gets a shot where he flips the camera so
you get this shot of just guys climbing
on the wall but this wall of water comes
from the left side of the screen just
it's so scary a scene in the movie I'm
like I don't think I've seen that shot
out of side of like the 10 commandments
inside that it really shows you that
like
impact of just water and it's like oh
there it is doom and it's very
disconcerning but you can and
it's a good it's a good mix Oh cause you
had these nice wide shots up but you
also have a lot shots where you really
feel like you're in the act and it's a
good mix up you know we talked about
Saving Private Ryan sometimes we say
there's even though I like for the most
part some attack train that it's a
little too much shaky-cam sometimes uh
you know to a point it's a little too
much like you're in the action there's
not like a good do any variety guy never
ask you to be swinging that I never feel
like I'm out of it yeah one comes
attention take that 20 minutes from
saving Brian and make it an hour for it
yeah that's why I was exhausted by the
time in this movie and that's anarchist
thing I don't make very clear this is
not it with exception maybe the people
on this little boat as a family on this
boat this is not a very clinical
character driven movie this is very much
like Black Hawk Down yeah it will tell
you lean about people trying to get away
but there's it's a problem account I
think it's more of a pro in this I think
those movies can work okay if they're
done well and I think this is done well
um the other thing I like um no it
proved to me and I've had this theory
for a long time that you don't I mean we
complain about the lack of gran things
but there's certain films or it's just
like okay this just needed the gore like
that would have been the fun of it you
don't need it here know like visit pg-13
film and damn if it didn't feel like an
r-rated movie to me even though it's B's
you know I wouldn't even think about
what I was like it is intense enough
that was like I would take no child what
whatever well I'm gonna say before
technically you know on a gore level and
stuff like that I mean if it's not
enough no no this could be PG this could
be a PG movie I do the gun right now eg
yeah I think the intensity is what we
ended up on a bag thank you there's no
CGI blood which is a huge problem I have
with modern Gore is it always relies on
a lot of CGI and it still kind of takes
me out of it a bit and you never had
that problem here because by not
emphasizing the gore you didn't have to
go to a CGI trick like that I didn't I
didn't notice I'm sure there's CGI all
over this um I didn't notice a lot of it
which is a huge plus
yeah I rarely agree they're very rare
there
nothing that stands out to me as though
that was obvious CG you know or that
with CG again and that could be because
I was just so invested out so it's like
then uh but ya know thinking back I'm
like how with you of course there has to
be teaching this funny thing I can't
think of any moments like oh yeah that
was audio cg is now ccg like it's one of
the things where it just it did sort of
blend very seamlessly and I won't have
to bet it's easy to believe the stuff is
really there and I think part of that is
because you know this is it strange
because it's both a bigger and a smaller
war movie this is this like Private Ryan
where the greatest thing all these
people going to get each other and
shooting and tasting all over Mike Ross
so there's definitely a lot of
three-window you're actively to
vocations yeah I love to practice I'm
just like it is sort of all the stuff
that you think it's like planes flying
and people on boats and explosions and
stuff I mean it's very much like it's
kind of on the speech and the planes
that sort of just focusing on one person
at a time there's a little boat of this
family that we're following that's going
to occur as well the things where it's
like it feels no very big and very small
percent I feel like that's what the best
war movies yeah and I think the other
thing I like about this is it's a
different way a ghost yes um let's came
early it is a it's a story that needs to
be told that is not American um because
America is the
basically seat of the film industry of
the world you know and I'm not going
like murdered you were say it just is um
you know most of the stories are aimed
at us and so most of these stories you
can throw millions of dollars that are
all American this is a story that you
know I think the Brits know well
obviously and Churchill's speeches
vigilance I think there's a lot of evil
rest world but they don't know it they
know the big events of World War two but
Dunkirk may not be something they're
aware so it's something different to see
I was aware of Dunkirk with the the
intricacies of it I wasn't and then
somebody's had to sit through crappy
movies like Pearl Harbor like this was
but the Pearl Harbor movie I won
Iowa
I think you know if you really want to
show your you know dedication to the
military and all that they've done it's
like this is the movie you know anyways
swarmers moves the military and waving
the American flag it's like you know you
want to show helpings your dad catches
the military you you show a film like
this you make the best thing about it as
tents and as exhausted as I was I was
still watching it where's the
Transformers movies are just as loud and
just as obnoxious with their sound
effects individuals and but I get I
literally just get bored I fall asleep
whereas this one I left in shell-shocked
like holy like I couldn't sleep we
fell like a seven o'clock show I didn't
go to bed till 2:30 in the morning
tonight I was just wired uhm but
yeah so it's it's just a story you you
don't see often and the closest thing
we've got is tora tora tora um it's kind
of dated it's there's some similarities
there's not a lot of character in that
but honestly I feel this is the better
movie so a cool jealous you know
there's not an American bamboo it's good
you know Saving Private Ryan I think is
the closest but that deviates on this
long and that's the other thing is I
like the fact that unlike Pearl Harbor
even to a certain degree Zane Brian so
it's not that Shmuel see like if there's
some schmaltz at the end a little bit
but it's earned you know a possession
well because I know you're talking about
okay so this ends big surprise for a
Nolan film with a speech but Eddie no no
there's so many he know what I thought
about there are so many reasons this
Beach works first of all it's a beach
that really exists MB is not something
that the real speed don't but the other
thing and I just I'd even think about
until now and this is brilliant it's you
know it's the we'll fight them on the
beaches well it's that speech but you
know how its dealt with churchills yeah
you know Elsa is not Churchill making
the speech it is one of the soldiers
reading the paper reading is almost very
mellow like you would read it and it's
showing everything has happened just
with and reading the paper I'm like
that's this movie this is the incredible
thing that happened but it's being told
through this small voice but a small
voice that is so important yeah
like to musical cues in the whole thing
that get a house with a transformer II
just this kind of like oh no no no but
but but very just kind of like soft
brass it's like this is our patriotic
moment like like and there's only two
moments in swimwear does that if one
involves the pilot and the other is at
the end when they're reading the speech
and it's it feels earned I like total
I'm like this gets technically a little
small see at the end but the whole damn
thing feels in other way there's one
more thing when all the boats arrive
which is not a spoiler you know that
because the trailer that's just the
story of what happens um okay we don't
do all that that could be in any right
yes all of those moments feel earned
when they do that versus like you know
need that those hints of less yeah so it
just it managed to do this without being
completely overly schmaltzy about it and
in many ways I go to worked way better
than obviously Pearl Harbor which is not
a good movie but even better than
something like Saving Private Ryan which
I've always done was a little overrated
but I'm like it's a good movie yeah wow
you say this one really like nailed it
no I mean and yeah Private Ryan though
I'm with you I like it I would say I
like it enough there's so many things
are well done that movie but yeah there
is a lot of shamil burning spin the
Sawyer's Nolan isms in this film this
Spielberg isms in that one yeah as most
as always one of his bigger stuff and I
think I nailed it with it earned it
because I know it's ironic cuz that's a
champion serum like what an awful
business a real thing no so last words
hey buddy no pressure no guilt but he's
my doing words earn it good guy account
well but like here's the thing too is
that so many of these war movies start
out and you don't even just war movies
movies don't want scene big start out
like we're already big we've already hit
it and we're going to treat the whole
movie like that and
and is build it's a fella but I thought
what the omens are at the end yeah no no
it starts off small and builds and
builds the business is kind of like what
I want Fellowship of the Ring I wanted
to start small builders that you don't
get to that play again I know but but
that this film does that right where
what it does get to those moments where
you have kind of a throw a better word
ish multi sappy musing in like no you
need this and you feel it you know you
not only know any that you want it again
it's been so tense but but again
nuts so far that it's like okay like we
finally get it you know we finally gets
a little bit of reward and it's just
like you they say hunger is the best
spice you know that's what it is like
we're just hungry for something to latch
on to and he gives it to us at the end
and I on that level I think the film is
brilliant but again I mean very
important to emphasize I mean this is
definitely a a film where the actions
defined books are it is not the dialogue
um I think this is where like some of
the Nolan isms creeped in a bit for me
everything is wanted you want to go into
like our few like negatives like I took
out some good sense to say audition no
no oh nice oh no I mean it can kind of
tie you in in a sense but God you know
we love Kenneth Branagh even when he's
bad we love Him because he's one of
these people words like he's a great
actor he's also very handy actor you
know and even he'll acknowledge bad you
know you can always can see the ego and
there and stuff this is what the sales
were I know it I need it in this film
man I mean it's what we had one of the
few like kind of like he has this
ability even when he schmaltzy to like
give you kind of a little bit of a sense
of warmth and you needed that so like
hope and warmth was about the only time
I was imparting in this film and I'm
like I need it no but I bought
it but and they're like oh yeah I felt
like oh I'm watching you in a pound at
him he is thingy I mean he's the master
of that when the boats coming just oh
yeah I mean it was love you're good
like not a few times we're just like I
like I just wanted that so much I'm like
oh please just give me the little taste
of him like just enough like some
sentimentality I'll take it I'll take
the sentimentality and he delivered it
it did not feel over the top and maybe
that's because we do see Branagh doing
over the top so much but in a great way
a I'm not seeing him going it only felt
over the top just because everything
else was so not to such a degree than
any other movie that would have just
been a normal scene but to me it felt a
little over the top but I feel like
that's what they were going for and it
needed that and I'm grateful they did it
just because I'm like okay I need to eat
like it's weird you almost need an
occasional cool sherry just latch on
through a little just to be like okay
like a little break let's go gonna mmm a
Hollywood movie moment yeah and there's
definitely parts where I'm like okay I
like a lot of this you know I kind of
figured they're taking liberties uh you
know to add to the suspense and just
sort of add you know I mean it's
Hitchcockian I have to feel that like
okay some of these things probably
either didn't happen or didn't happen
quite as suspenseful yeah I made that
that uh but but it worked it pulls you
more in and I think in any true story
Zoe I didn't present my my guess is
something gonna change I think very
interest how much is actually true and
how much is just he came up with
fictional characters to insert into the
battle to in part which I am a problem
with well yeah you know giving us a
sense of what was going on is yep a meal
for them it does feel real and I like I
like that wasn't able to tell for the
most part yeah there's something that we
could tell um and then I guess the last
thing we'll talk about that it probably
other people are talking about that this
is told in different time lengths once a
week once a day once an hour
um surprisingly I knew this going over
all it work but yeah I cuz when I heard
them like a price because I'm like you
know so it's the only way it never tells
these in the right order he plays with
time or something like that but they was
a few time you can work and it works
here it it works
and the way they intersect is cool like
I like seeing the different points of
view in the way these three stories kind
of like intersect at random moments
there's pitfalls to that and I'll get
into that but its overall like I didn't
have a good very idea of doing that I
think it's cool
I didn't have a problem with it um I do
joke I'm just like god help us with this
guy ever tries to tell a story like in
the correct order in order yeah like
richest she is teeth
how do those forget it at it I mean II
need all this movies had something to do
with playing around with time in one way
or they're even interstellar uh and when
he does it obviously those elements I'm
trying to think if I've ever had a
problem with it I don't think I have I
usually been okay with them um my
problem with a cookie on the others
feels like you didn't direct that I know
we only produced it and no bread and
stuff but I'm like that that didn't work
I am I have technical problems with it's
hard to explain but for somebody who
uses different timelines I feel like
sometimes the shots don't connect or
land properly and the okay the weird
thing is in this movie he's got it
proves something I thought for a while
but I'm like okay I got it now what the
problem is because I would feel like I'm
watching an incomplete film even in this
way I'm like do something it feels
incomplete about this what is it he has
a sense of the big picture really well
genius-level his big shots are amazing
when it comes to small shops like the
small picture that's where you get
tripped up if there's a fistfight in the
Nolan film if there's a drowning seen in
the Nolan film any of that he confuses
just well I'm just going to show chaos
with somehow that's the right call and
you end up just getting confused and
pulled out of it and it's so such a
jarring just to position between the
bigger shots that he does I think I'm
dark nice this was this was a huge issue
I had in a dark night like for for
instance uh you know you would get the
giant shots of him over Hong Kong trying
the way the truck flipping all of that
great you put Batman
in a close-quarters fistfight good
lot trying to figure out what
the hell you're looking at and it just
comes off as confusing and then you miss
certain plot points I was like there was
one or two times in this memorize in
this yeah and I my way I had no this is
the first time I barely remembered it I
was trying to put it in my head you
missed it I miss it I know a number of
people who miss it and it's because it
shot so it's poorly you just can't make
out what's good as a perfect it's the
chaos of warp some genius of the art or
no it's just bad like I'm sorry it's
just I got a lot of the clothes stuff
and a lot of them work but you're right
there are times right what are you going
on and icing bad big walking on a face
and it's a close-up that's fine if it's
a close-up action scene you have a 50/50
shot that it's going to be composed well
enough to make out what's going on
no you know it's a huge problem I'll say
this I did notice a character died I
didn't know it was that character like I
did pick up on the notice because I see
the drowning hand yeah it's like I don't
know who that was no I know you had to
ask me afterwards that I'm just like
well I like oh I I'm just gonna fart oh
no and it creates confusion in the plot
and it's just well like the Dark Knight
the big themes all I'm ahead of the
curve and the long discussions and and
these big moments yet little things like
at the end I still am just confused with
like it's just a little bit's the
minutiae oh yeah how did you know all of
this even with that idea how did he know
no not even that but just like when
Batman's putting all the lives together
giving the guns yeah yeah I don't know
what he's doing there
did I miss something somehow Batman can
fall from you know 40 stories I know the
building they shot that at it's in
downtown Chicago you know on the river
that's like a 40-story building falls
lands on the car with Rachel in tow
survives not a problem and yet at the
end to phase takes a two to three story
dive up at Atlanta and the
shot and put together I didn't even know
he was dead or not yet I was just
staring at him like and then when they
had the memorial picture I'm like well
Jessie died like it's the little scenes
where he drops the ball that I find so
weird because he has a great visual eye
for giant scenes but he has this
terrible eye for smaller scenes and then
when you put him together it always
feels like his movie is strange
incomplete or he doesn't show like a
transition to get from one scene to
another so you just left with this
jarring cast and I am so sick of be with
him is this really something to see
because it's put you on edge you don't
know I'm like no it's bad storytelling
we don't know how to face got out of
that car after he shot the book out
which sucks because I think he is so
good at so many other things like it's
not to do piss on Nolan's he's terrible
I think he's a genius but I feel like
that's some sort of weird trade up like
the power of genius is always like
you're really good at some things but
not in the other that is where he drops
the ball and it's a similar problem in
this film there's just these little
scenes where happens I'm like what
like I didn't follow and you can tell me
it's like oh it's because you don't
understand the timeline you're not smart
don't think there's the time lights is
visual storytelling but so much of the
rest of this movie has some of the best
visual storytelling you ever seen that
I'm is like guess I'll take it it's a
Nolan ISM uh so that was one problem I'd
say one of my other grace is with the
characters in this film the family on
the boat I think is strong you get about
12 lines of dialogue in the whole movie
yeah yeah yeah in the whole movie that
give you a sense of who they are what
they are you know there's I about you
know his son was in the RAF you know
this I won't give spoilers away but
little lines here and they're killing
and Murphy's character you know I
understand where he's coming from
even the pilots and the pilots are
Rangeley enough yeah and they're a
special case because they're supposed to
only have one hour of time basically
after following them so much that's
mostly battle its battle and just flying
to the location I had a sense of who
they were made me through the visual
storytelling whether it was the biggest
gripe I have with
movie is the two or three main
characters on the beach that aren't the
officers kenneth branagh ray Fiennes I
did not know them any better by the end
of this movie that I did it the first uh
I know one guy wanted to take a I
know they all wanted to get off the
beach I'll make a little I'll make a
little bit of an argument for that
because I'm every year telling me that
going in I thought I was gonna think the
same thing I like that these two
particularly the two guys the third guy
you're right I can't read it even who he
was or where he came from or whatever
but the second guy I was saying like you
know are the two guys that can start off
with I like how they don't know each
other they kind of just immediately kind
of get this connection really fast of
like and we're just sort of stuck
together I'm doing this you wanted okay
away we're kind of doing it and they
just sort of keep helping each other out
and without saying anything pretty much
it's a little pain you know or huh I
mean it's like that's it but there tends
to be a connection especially in a war
film where you just kind of make friends
really fast through a situation without
having to really know much about again
no but then there's kind of a twist in
this you know where something is
revealed about a person and here's what
robbing it's always trying to be figured
out what's going to be done you know
it's one of those things where it's like
no but that's that's not right that's
not it's because you did kind of go
through this stuff without talking very
much to omit stuff and it's one of those
things where I feel like yeah what okay
I can't work or not what did it amount
you though knowing where the movie goes
um no no I can't no guess are the wrong
trying to go off the beach and it's like
it even at the end
Kevin promises I'm staying for the
French you know and it is one of the
things where it's like it's and you got
sort of this connection of you know
soldiers and then you know civilians
coming in trying to help and stuff like
that what do you know about him what
have you what have you gained from any
of this oh I mean I love you like that
guys like five minutes I know about
three times yeah I feel like I don't
need to know too much I get that said
but I guess yes another prosecutor not a
case of I don't need to know too much
cuz I didn't know too much about the
family or the pilots
like I mean when you look at it the
pilot
a special that is bare bones as bare
bones as it gets is just that I don't
need to know too much about them I just
need to know something anything and I
got zero and it doesn't mean like I'm
not watching the film going well I don't
care therefore I hope they die like I
hope they survived but I didn't get a
single thing out of it and the excuse I
keep hearing is well it took place in a
barrel so you can't well okay but here's
the problem
it's a week a day in an hour those three
guys on the beach got the full week and
you can't tell me that there was no
moment where they could sit down for a
second just a heat and maybe
have one line of dialogue that would
just give now but they okay guys I went
where's your friend go oh he's a looking
for a way out I say again again I think
there is something yeah he's up okay we
would have to go to spoiler corner for
this but there's a reason for that but
they not know anything about their
character I mean like I feel I thought
it did I thought it did at first until
the twist and I'm like oh so really
wasn't reviewing much about the
character it's not no but I feel like I
don't know and somehow I felt like they
were especially and tying into just all
these people trying to get off and who
they are and stuff like that and I I
don't know I felt like in the overall
theme and idea of the movie I felt like
it were no no me when it came to the
family and the pilots kept building you
kept learning a little more about the
characters when even though you started
off at Absolute Zero like a lot of
people will put character development to
start in the beginning just a little bit
to get you hooked quick he didn't do
that with the pilots in the family the
weird thing was but I feel like that
time with them spent together just all
the attempts not working to try a
different sense that doesn't work to get
a new guy that I feel like that to
secure that guy feels about them trying
to make a connect it was all spent just
running ducking but I feel like that
connection that's not that's just doing
so here's no no but there's they're
people that have never met and suddenly
they're doing these things together just
then doing these things again they're
actually being defined that's what's
kind of drawing them together sometimes
it's lists sometimes they come back
together and they just sort of keep
going through these experiences together
so that when it does come to that time
where the twist is there
like they've had this experience the
experiences what kind of throw together
even though they never really good that
was the weakest part of the movie was
when they turn on each other in the boat
that's like one of the few moments are
like oh my god this just turned into
like a standard Hollywood love action
really no I were just like art you know
you're right dad I was like are you
kidding me invisible movie he's
like we're going to do this like a like
scene that goes back to the dawn of time
like that was like it didn't record but
I was like a flawless means of moving
I'm like wow that's where it got the
weekends like it just turned to the Lord
of the Flies for a second like really I
don't know in a war movie I feel like
those things do happen and they need to
happen this is about all these people
trying to get off and they're trying to
get on together and now we're not going
to be a crow fighting each other I care
but that's part of the problem is you're
trying to identify with these characters
and then you just have them turn
on each other and all the sudden I'm
going wait a second like I'm not it's
just I'm not that invested in any of
those three on the beach that they were
following it's strange because usually
like usually I would be on the same boat
like I don't know enough about these
people but there is something about NGOs
going through the experience
particularly in a war movie I'm like I
should if you're going to follow
somebody through life and death I should
have just something anything I mean you
can complain about a spear your game
they're like you can complain about Mad
Max but that still told you at the
beginning that he lost its weapon nobody
really liked though he really can't know
those little things like when he's
walking baggies you know on the bridge
and just those little connections I feel
like those go a long way in war and they
go a long way in a war move it when I am
working obligated than watching a Tom
and Jerry cartoon but but I do feel
there's a connection with a legit and in
something that we're being told is the
greatest war boy the greatest war movies
of all time it is it is a weakness it
isn't a story the movie but see I feel
like the experience the experience is
what's drawing them together and the
fact that they are just just the little
things helping each other out go a long
way and I feel like that there was
become a band of brothers at some point
you still have
going a down time or if you go through
an experience you know there's still a
bit like there's still kind of a
beginning and end he only chose chose it
was Nolan's decision to choose to show
us only the moments where they're just
running around out of the weeks worth of
time if this was one hour if you're just
like this is one hour of Dunkirk these
guys just met they've got one hours
they're in the middle of a battle boom
one dies or something of a split up and
that was it so he said I get that but
with a week's worth of time like you
can't give me one line and I'm not
sitting you're going I want Nolan's
speech is like no I could have taken
like was is an hour forty minute movie
five lines of dialogue or less good is
that a tow lines of dialogue even like
they go on the ship and they're eating
there and the only line of Elega guess
is you want to quick exit like it
there's just I think no one thought that
that was enough just to show the actions
I don't think I don't think it is it
doesn't wreck the movie but whenever it
cut back to them whenever I saw it I'm
just like yeah like I hope they live and
I'm interested in the visuals but I'm
not really into them I don't know it's
they are like a because I mean I I
should be agreeing with any cuz
everything you say is right but I mean
it's one of those things where it's like
preserving their work for me for some
reason we can Arana when the ships come
in exacting where you're from and you
know we're from Ares that's great
brilliant like it's just like little
lines like that do so much just so much
I think that's what people forget it's
like when two actors are talking and
engaging they're not just engaging the
other actor they're engaging us the
audience they are talking to us and
saying who I am what I am doing you know
why I am here and so and I'm not saying
that you needed just speeches and
speeches but to remodel where is he a
couple entirely because all I got from
all their faces and stuff was fear and
exhaustion and I get it it's Dunkirk you
want fear and exhaustion but there is
still there a weak like you could show
fear in exhaustion I got that out of the
pilots too they're flying for an hour
the frustration of trying to shoot that
guy down and
everything but I just felt more of a
connection with the pilot and the people
on the boat than I did these three who
has yet a whole weeks of time worth to
tell the story yeah I mean I see it I
mean it's one of those things where it's
like I think the experience does help
them episode if they Nolan Nolan isn't
because that's a common criticism of his
movies and one that I generally agree
with I think see holy movie where I had
the most connection with a character was
the Dark Knight I think it's more
because that's built into the character
from scratch because it's someone else's
arvan and again Batman Begins - yeah
it's with those who think that's because
the character was already prefab it was
pretty ribbon it's a common prison no
movies and this one is no different he
he doesn't well with the family and the
pirate very a lot of the family yeah I
bought that I bought kill him okay Kiwi
murphy's characters there is there's a
great example not a whole lot of
dialogues nothing but fear and
exhaustion and he's nuts but I knew who
that was I could get that from the
performance and I could get it for him
why could you do that with them on the
beach I feel like again sort of that
like there's there's a lot of barrier in
between them not knowing much about the
other and stuff like that they serve
like okay but we have this connection
that we're both in this together now
we're just we're kind of helping each
other out just in little ways you yell
meals that little say I'll help you with
this little thing yeah you know you help
me with that help you with this and just
these little things that like I said I
think because of this setup because of
this scenario hold up and that is the
connection but I know what you're saying
to do it it's like if you don't care too
much because you don't have enough it's
15 I'll say this it's 50% there you know
they say actions speak louder than words
that's great so that gives me the 50%
you know from their actions but it still
we're in a war movie so I feel like well
that's going to happen anyway that's you
throw them in that environment a shot
there good well okay you've got cowards
and stuff like that but it's I'm not
watching what they're doing going oh I'm
so surprised I've gleaned so much from
the fact that they want to help each
other out or get the hell out of the war
zone like that
that just generally will kind of go with
the territory so I'm just like I don't
know just something to latch on right
what you're saying but I think you know
the other network okay the only other
gripe I have is the way they presented
the timeline so okay I know so many
people who got lost in this film and if
the typical Nolan fanboy ever since as
always you're just not smart enough to
understand what's going on I walked out
you yelling at me at the beginning of
this reviews and you're way too hard I
know and you've done nothing but the
knowing fans wither because no no no no
no I have way less of Brahma Nolan than
I do with his defense as the I the Nolan
fandom drives me up a wall because it's
always the same excuse if you have a
criticism Nolan it's your gesture
understand what Norman is brilliant talk
to or or like because we're all too
stupid to figure it out or the other one
I like is just what critics brilliance
of it because you need to share a second
time so therefore you learn more motive
whatever that's the problem and I don't
think that would be intended you know
clearly says it again where you are you
know has a number for it I don't like
it's homework and then yeah the span
that taken up and glue it right I mean
that's the only way to put it on but the
funny thing is you brought it up before
going in because everyone sort of told
me about this time thing so it's like I
had idea going in that help me out and
stuff but like what I saw it I was like
you know if I saw this for the first
time this this wouldn't strain this out
for me that this would make it clear
what's going on and it's not something
where it's like what you need to see it
again that that's the snow present and
mid nothing oh yeah it doesn't you
actually it takes away from it's not
like like there are some Nolan films
where it's like you see the second time
and it it adds something this is a case
where it by not knowing that of how the
timeline works it adds nothing
it only takes away from the movie
because you're spending time to rigor
what the hell am I looking at um it
doesn't anything I saw the second time
I'm like did anything emotionally I just
knew from the beginning okay this is
what I'm seeing so there had to be
better way to do that I will say this
and when I saw it I was asking myself my
first thought is man the toughest part
of writing the script I bet you anything
you're the thing that went to the most
rewrites or them trying to figure out is
how do we explain how this is going out
what the timelines are and stuff like
that and yes it's easy to say that
wasn't the right way but I feel like if
I said I knew the right way I love well
there is one by one I don't have it I
don't know there's one key mistake and
that is no mention of what the mole is
is made until probably 15 20 minutes
into the book yeah cuz I caught the mole
because the mole could be someone trying
to and that you know and no router no
one is not an idiot
he knows the audience he's making this
for this is going to be in America even
though it's a British story he has to
know most people would know that you
know you may know what Dunkirk is but
you're not going to know the technicals
of the beachheads name was the mole or
the the area that the Nazis surrounded
the Allies was called the mole like and
to not mention that particularly when
you a opening text he had an
opening text where he laid it up all you
need to do is insert us Dunkirk - at a
place codenamed the mole or something -
finish the rest of your sentence right
there you would have no more yet another
way to do it the the soldier comes in he
tries to stand in line with any of those
people one of them just look to them for
loans as welcome to the moooo mate like
just so there was no way to establish it
before you cut to all the other
timelines but if you do that though then
they may know what's actually going on
and heaven forbid so and that was a
problem and it's not that like I already
had like some fans like I guess we were
just too dumb to figure it out like no
it's just all it said was the mole one
week I I thought that I was like well I
didn't realize there was a German spy at
Dunkirk but maybe it's a German spy and
then when it said this the see one day
I'm like okay now I'm confused I'm like
well maybe they're a day out unlike is
the mole like an operation when the Nazi
they're going to take I'm like wait
maybe the mole is a ship that's coming
in maybe the more like you know it never
established what the mole was until
kenneth branagh finally mentions a
twenty minutes in and it's such a
jumbled quick line you blink and you
miss it and then the second time is
mentioned is in the middle of a movie
where it's more prominent so if you
don't know that going in that this is
how the timeline works like it's not
that people are dumb it's just super
easy if you didn't like catch on that
that's what that actually meant to get
confused there's a movie I don't like
the movie by thing as a brilliant setup
it's called the hours and it very
quickly and very cleverly sets up what's
going on it shows you know shows you
three different timelines one two in
Virginia Woolf once with this housewife
and another is with like an I forget
Monroe Street place but it's something
in current time it shows Virginia Woolf
writing the lines and the lines of you
know I think I'll pick up flowers this
evening that cuts of Julianne Moore
reading it years later I think I'll pick
up flowers this evening and then cut to
meryl streep years later just say honey
I think I pick up flowers this evening
and that immediately sets up the three
different time lines sort of what the
connection is and what the theme is and
it was one of the things young like that
was brilliant there's a way abstract
idea being presented there knowingly and
so glaring ways to do it and I'm not
buying the excuse I like what's just you
plebeian on Nolan fans are too stupid to
figure I'm on I'm from a smart guy I
know like and that's the thing once you
once you know exactly how it works
I don't find it difficult to follow gets
a slightly difficult oh I went in
knowing and I want to know it yeah and
followed it fine because I told you yeah
I might just know this going in I didn't
have to explain anything else except
when it all I got week one day let's
mean how to do for an hour thrown off
and then they got they figured it out
it's like okay and you haven't here's
the reason why I think it was not
intentional loves to do the little aha
it was this all along like he does later
in this there is a little bit of a twist
it's like you yeah I just went
there was no moment for that it was it
was just a little too pretentious for me
just like it is the way was presented
one period the mall underlined - one
week - this and I don't get something to
hold me that I was that you told me on
the phone but far as I am I was like it
doesn't seem that bad but something
about what I saw them like when you try
God there is just like and the funny
thing is I honestly thought it was a
really cool way mystical - story yeah
you burn out that it's out of order or
that it's too hard to follow it if you
know it's it's not insanely difficult to
follow you said to readjust your mind
just ever so slightly but I didn't find
it very difficult but it's just not
knowing that going in I spent 20 minutes
of the movie going what is the mole is
there a Germans fine that I'm like we'll
wait why is it night here and not day
another like you know and then finally
it hit me like oh it's being told in
three and I'm like why need just
like find a better way to say that okay
no surprises in this movie is what's
behind the corner when are we going to
get him it the surprise is not what's
going on it not twists and turns like
dart and I adore inception and
everything and that's the bad away
you're supposed to get this very when
the way he set it up though it turns it
into it twists and anybody who says with
hemming just see the movie a second time
to let know you don't learn jack
no I don't get a sentential I think
you're about to get very quickly what
was going on how it's being presented
and stuff and on that on that level he
talking Bachchan and you know but it's
still I think it's a great movie and if
you know that going in like that's your
chichi I think it's fine it's just the
way he presented that just drove via the
wall and you know more Tom Hardy yet
again another film where he has to have
all over his face this poor guy
yeah I like Johnny Depp that I makeup
it's like just a given I almost I almost
wish that because I had forgotten when I
saw the second time I'm like oh you do
see their faces right before they put
the mask
yeah great but I almost wish they had
the mask on for beginnings at the end
it's reviewers like we're driving
because I miss like I like wasn't really
like I was listening to the dialogue and
still in my head running through what
the hell is the mall and like I really
wasn't painted edge of their faces so
they put the masks on so I kind of
forgotten them he takes the bascomb at
the end of like oh my god it's tell
Marty like I wasn't putting it together
in my head like I want like my flying is
like a German plane is like you know
read my turn my back up the German her
betrayal girl I think one more one more
swiping just really quickly as the one
other pitfall of this style of
storytelling is I think it was really
cool to tell the story in this way is
there is like it's a slight spoiler so
one of Tom Hardy's pilot friend goes
down and Tom Hardy watches this happen
then you see the plane hit and then the
pilot like waves and Tom Hardy's like oh
yeah takes up okay so you see what
happens after that later in the story
the pilots waving because it's like oh
I'm drowning it's like the flames
the plans in the movie looks like I'm
okay and in real life he's like ah that
that is cool I like that but one pitfall
I was trying to explain to people on my
facebook if they weren't getting it
because I but he was just show what
happen if I was I get that I'm not
stupid
I'm like the problem though is is like
we know for a fact from what no one
chose to show us that the plane land
safely and the pilot is waving so we
know he survives the impact he's there
he's waived
for whatever reason I can't figure it
out Nolan like the the people on the
boat are watching this plane crash and
all you need to do we show the people on
the boat their point of view of the
plane hitting and then cut to the guy
like almost things like ocean turn
instead he he like does one of those
shots I think he just wanted a cool
shatters everybody does this shot where
he's like on the wing and the planes
going down and the hans zimmer music
jung chung took like oh my god
will he survive really
Ranjan and I'm sitting there as old I'm
going like but we know he made it
because he was waving tell you know I'll
go I know I'll go one further like that
no I did what I didn't get it you know I
thought this is where we going with it
as he's flying over he sees Hardy sees
the boat of the family heading towards
them so it's like mom and we're going to
get well first of all you know they're
going to get there but Meghan won't get
there in time a guy usually kind of
drowning and stuff like that but you
have them arguing we have to go for the
places no no as someone does that
nobody's dead and you know could be a
survivor we know they're going there yes
suppose I have this argument death it is
just because in that shot you would
receive that boat heading straight yeah
that's what I own Ovi honestly like okay
I'm really torn because I like I like
that character of the pilot and he did
serve some purpose later and I like him
watching his Tom Hardy try to shoot down
that one plane like come on me come on
get him but there is a partner was like
it would have been a much more pointed
tragic story
if he drowned because there's just like
the needs of the many all these other
guys we have to pick up or about to be
taken over by the Nazis out waving these
is this one dude like cuz II like that
guys deliver their libraries I harbor
partner or something like I was like oh
my god he's going to do it he's going to
just keep going I I'm torn like I I I'm
okay with them saving him even it was a
Hollywood moment but the same time I'm
also wondering like woman but were you
actually before well again we don't I
don't really happen but yeah I started
out a lot has happened as they
technically yes my own there's something
if Nolan does is kind of thing again
it's your turn okay if you're going to
show us what happened to these guys to
begin with don't milk the suspense like
oh my god is you're going to survive the
crash like because we know he made it as
far as hitting the water and that's the
last technical but that part afterwards
no it's really cool again without any
any spoilers or anything but there is
something with one of the planes the
propeller stopping and it's like okay we
know you can still get some good airtime
in the air after a half but there oh my
god capital that was I think I let's do
not at all
there's a ton of thing about law oh my
god turning around really quick making
like this landing for super far away and
it's like okay I really feel like this
is not how we're even though you can
still get some good they're kind of like
maybe yeah so he's in a Spitfire he's
maybe 3,000 feet up it looks like
judging by you know where they're
filming it the propeller runs out so I
guess you want to say this is spoiler
material yeah let's just so yeah it's
good movie you don't know a great movie
but for a movie that's so realistic in
so many ways this just drove me up a
wall so the propeller runs out now if
you know anything about aircraft you can
still glide in safely you all you need
the speed you know to keep going but
eventually you will lose their speed and
you'll start to go down so you have to
glide down somehow about what looks like
3,000 feet up in the air this guy is
able to just keep floating for what
seems like fricking ever do a full 180
yeah no no they're not you round down
another Nazi fighter and then continues
to just keep speeding off and I'm like
my god no no like the second that thing
goes out you've got to start looking for
a place I guess just waiting for that
plane to here you know be going down
just at the right moment to hit him
because he can't help over down because
that all-sec working with it's one of
the is one of the most amazing oh wow
I'm like it's just a little tool area
but I just want han Solo be like quick
shot kid that was one in a million
like it's just do it so like I'm like no
no honey head yeah Hollywood movie
though that's the only lot you're gonna
get comments like actually see Riddick
link American oh yeah okay example yeah
eggs possible honey are you likely I'm I
don't know it seemed very very barrel I
just had so many questions yeah yeah it
was a Hollywood moment I I mean it was
cool seeing that thing coming but I
probably would have preferred it if like
he just continued to glided no I want I
mean in that moment cuz all yeah shortly
on at all but yeah I was just
immediately asking how is that possible
or just even how likely is that I mean
what are the buzzer
I'm just like in a movie that was still
this great like I mean that maybe it was
like a miracle moment that happened in
one day I'll basically talk about the
things that take it from an a-plus movie
to a high a movie but this is a 95%
movie yeah oddly I know does this and it
was it was an experience on IMAX that I
won't forget like it is a big screen
film scene on the big screen - you deny
me if you can see it and I ah yeah I
would even argue maybe SDX get close to
this criticism that like is it's
definitely a very impressive big screen
film and really for the intent of making
you feel like you're really there it's
not there just to show off the
landscapes up it's like you really this
feels worked because you feel like yeah
no one is best at tension and big
picture and he gets he nails both those
things and we don't have the nolan ism
of all the crazy reams of dialogue so it
I honestly this is good I think this is
my favorite since dark night night yeah
yeah uh you know and the fine thing is
uh this summer like you know it's
usually like it's been amazing
really even the movies we have problems
with we feel like like I like spider-man
if I have problems I like valerian yeah
they're like alluring with ib4 kind of I
want war from the Planet of the Apes um
carnies rants farmers that all right
yeah guardians in a galaxy - I really
liked baby driver Wonder Woman baby
drive wonder on that phone I think
that's of there's transformer yeah
I am like alien covenant at all um but I
you know they spend some but I just
feel like the number of good movies
versus the bed though like we usually
have more bad like we have more than I
think back but oh yeah yeah been really
somewhat a few times where I'm like oh
crap like there's so many movies I have
to add is that I told I know got you
want to plan B if I want the atomic
blonde I need there's like all these
movies coming out were it's just like
it's hard to keep up with so many good
movies and I feel like that's a good
problem to have you know oh I don't know
like that even
as a bad ones have had you know like we
kind of like Belarus there's going to be
one of those after the dumpster fire
that was 2016 there's going to be one of
the summers they look back on like yeah
despite everything else going on in the
world this is amazing yeah yeah good
good movie season so long and and to be
fair like transformers did decent
overseas but didn't do great here so
even some of yeah some of the Bitcoin
like normally bringing the money that we
hate not doing spectacular no a lot
better oh yeah like pirates didn't do as
well you know yeah yeah I nearly a
confident didn't do that yeah that was
about every piece like you know I
feeling coming to maven the bathroom I
still don't think it's that good yeah no
I feel like it's one of those where it's
like so trying the newer stuff you know
just I know like not relying on old
tricks just making good boot camp and
those that are relying on the old tricks
like yeah well if they're catching on
you know I mean though they're not doing
as well they can still date okay but
they're they're catching on so what yeah
but more we better probably all over I
mean this is good summer so far so I'm
thinking that I I can't wait to see more
of the play of eh I don't know if I'll
do a video on that one I might just do
like a Facebook post but yeah at some
point I'll get to that girls I need to
see them you will believe in it can make
you cry okay so now you will believe any
circus you probably get a special
Academy or he'll get a lot of honorary
Oscars years later you know that's what
they're going to do um and the
honorarium frog suit Oscar goes to honor
a Oscar for doing okay right yeah it
should be an Oscar like wrapped in a
little green or gray frog suit or so but
yeah with like little yellow dots so um
yes that's about these guys we'll see
you next time
you